es muy difícil determinar que haya un
ganador con tantos muertos
particularmente en gaza'
sin embargo es ya histórico que tanto
israel como hamás cada vez que han
tenido un conflicto de estos ya van
cuatro siempre declaran la victoria es
una cuestión de propaganda lo que se
critica al gobierno de netanyahu con
respecto al no logró en gaza es que no
ha logrado disuadir a hamás ni siquiera
a terminar con todas sus lanzaderas de
cohetes y van a seguir probablemente en
una siguiente desafortunada futura ronda
tirando proyectiles a donde consigan
tanto a las comunidades colindantes con
gaza e incluso a tel aviv donde hemos
recibido también bastantes misiles por
su parte en gaza- seguramente la lectura
de una victoria tiene que ver con que
israel ha accedido a un alto el fuego
incondicional
las interpretaciones
y también hablamos sobre el papel
mediador del vecino egipto veamos
egipto es muy importante en este
conflicto en este conflicto y en los
cuatro anteriores que han tenido israel
y hamás desde gaza de hecho egipto
empezó a perfilarse como un factor de
conversación clave entre los islamistas
de hamas y el gobierno israelí desde que
israel se retiró de gaza en 2005 y
después cuando hamás ocupó el poder en
2007 y empezaron los conflictos abiertos
egipto siempre ha jugado un papel clave
de mediación y en esta ocasión también
comenzó a gestionar una posible un
posible alto el fuego o una tregua en el
primer día en el que se empezaron a
lanzar cohetes y lo ha conseguido ha
sido rechazado en varias ocasiones por
ambas partes y sin embargo fue recibido
ayer y han llegado a un marco de acuerdo
que ambos podían aceptar que es una
tregua sin condiciones